you can't force a cat to do stuff the
week you can quote unquote force the dog
you put more pressure on the dog just do
anything that means good the breeder
names in pride I was going to change his
name but it kind of fits really very
proud of himself very prideful he's an
exceptional captain
very interested in like they come with a
confidence in an animal like it looks
like it's something you read as far as
confidence is concerned you see the way
they carry themselves sometimes a little
more difficult to live with because it
has so much confidence in themselves are
you a little obnoxious but you need an
outgoing confident animal to be able to
go through the rigors of Hollywood on
each side
stay we tell people a dog or so pleases
trainer a coward should please
themselves leave the cat alone they can
be very animal aggressive in their very
you know very full of themselves cats
are very difficult animals work on set
their flight oriented animals that they
gets upset they're scared they're gonna
run before they think that something
spooks and then I want to take off part
of our deals we go to the location we're
working at a day or so in advance spend
20 30 minutes with the cats there then
when you go back the next time even
though it's changed because the French
are different and the production people
there in cameras etc they're in an
environment that's somewhat familiar
with to them much more comfortable feet
up cheetah
that's pride